j'ai connu j'ai connu la violence
j'ai côtoyé la violence pendant toute ma
période de professionnels et j'en ai je
n'ai pas échapper à la question suivante
la première est ce que la violence et la
violence
non il ya un truc est bon est ce que ça
va voilà c'est ça merci
est-ce que la violence et et
irrémédiable et voire indispensable
voire indispensable et la deuxième
question c'est de me dire est ce que il
y a moyen une voix humaine pour
éradiquer cette violence pour dépasser
cette violence g je me suis pas contenté
d'être sur le terrain
j'ai essayé de réfléchir au sujet et
j'ai trouvé deux auteurs qui m'ont
apporté des réponses
le premier auteur que joue ce signal
c'est clausewitz qui était le grand
théoricien militaire l'auteur de ces
femmes de cette fameuse formule
la guerre est le prolongement de la
politique par d'autres moyens
et puis le grand philosophe rené girard
rené girard qui nous apprend les codes
du mimétisme la violence je pense que le
mimétisme la violence est un des grands
ressorts de toutes ces grandes violences
que je vais essayer de vous faire
découvrir que j'ai vécu alors une
question aussi qui se pose est la
suivante
pourquoi devient ton aux fichiers et aux
militaires et officiers bon il est clair
que la petite enfance est importante
je suis issu d'une famille modeste qui a
vécu la guerre qui a été meurtri par la
guerre et qui a eu besoin de se
reconstruire avec des valeurs simples
des valeurs qui avaient été oubliés
pendant la période précédente et qui qui
nous a élevés dans ce type de valeurs il
y avait rien d'inné dans ma famille
c'est à dire qu' il ya des familles qui
ont toujours un militaire il y en avait
pas j'en avais pas avant au contraire
même j'avais des aïeux qui était plutôt
dreyfusards antimilitariste donc cesser
la première génération
pourquoi j'ai voulu être officiers
militaires et bien en découvrant un
certain nombre de choses notamment
lyautey le gnl maréchal lyautey c'était
un des ouvrages qui faisait partie de la
bibliothèque de la maison et j'avais été
impressionné par cet officier qui fait
campagne à madagascar qui arrive à
vaincre rabais havana grand seigneur
malgache et qui au lieu de le brûler au
lieu de lui couper la tête
le soir elle invite à sa table j'ai
trouvé que ça c'était un rôle du
seigneur de guerre c'était magnifique
et puis je me suis aussi un peu
identifié plus tard à un personnage que
vous voyez dans le fils devienne fou de
pierre schoendoerffer
lorsque le
lorsqu un moment donné à un garçon un
militaire va partir
il est sur le tarmac à sai dont il va
s'envoler dans un avion pour aller
sauter sur dien bien phu
1 il n'a jamais sauté en parachute 2 il
sait que saigon que dien ben phu va
tomber et le reporter qui est en train
de refaire l'interrogent et lui dit
pourquoi est il dit parce qu'il ya des
copains là bas donc quelque part je
pense je m'identifie à cette réflexion
et puis la dernière le dernier
questionnements et suivants est ce que
si c'était à refaire je le referais ben
je dis oui je signe tout de suite
bon voilà j'en ai terminé sur le petit
paragraphe pourquoi pour passer un autre
paragraphe c'est à dire le passage à
l'acte le passage à l'acte c'est simple
c'est sainte geneviève prépa à leur
simple je viens 1960 saint cyr 1962 et
je rentre à l'école d'artillerie en 1964
cette période est caractéristique d'une
pour moi d'une période historique et qui
est intéressante parce que finalement je
me rends compte que ma vie
professionnelle étaient plus liés à des
périodes historiques cas des périodes
personnel et cette période historique sa
période de la conscription
c'est la période de la fin de la
colonisation et donc nous ça c'est rien
à l'époque on a été formé sur des vieux
thème pas sur le thème qui va arriver en
1900 1966 qui va me faire et changer
d'époque et adopter un autre une
formation du loing une mission
totalement différente en 1966 nous
sommes par le général de gaulle
engagé comme acteur dans la guerre
froide avec un vecteur dit nucléaire
avec l'armé nucléaire et je fais le
choix sortant de l'école d'artillerie de
rentrer de servir une arme nucléaire
alors voilà l'armé nucléaire que j'ai
servi et là ya du pas possible bon
j'étais lieutenant donc j'ai servi
s'éteindre c'est une rampe qui est
capable de lancer une requête avec à 40
km bien noté avec une une arme terme au
nul à l'arme nucléaire simplement de 40
kilos tonnes c'est à dire deux fois
hiroshima 40 km 2 fois hiroshima et nous
avions en allemagne à peu près 300
lanceur de ce type entre les américains
les deux mois fatou les alliés donc ce
qui veut dire qu'en cas de tirs en cas
de conflit vous aviez à peu près 300
lanceur de 40 kilos tonnes à 40 km sur
l'europe ils auront et faut imaginer
qu'en face il y avait probablement sinon
autant peut-être le double de lanceurs
de leur soeur voilà ça c'était c'était
un premier choc le deuxième choc
je les ai eus lorsque j'ai posé une
question loin en tant que le yacht en
tenir
j'avais si j'avais un ordre de tir
j'avais une heure une heure de le
positionnement c'est à dire chargé la
roquette calculer les éléments
aérodynamiques enfin d'une sélection
avec une heure et j'avais posé la
question qui était tout à fait normal si
je perds le contact avec mon chef est ce
que qu'est ce que je fais il a réponse
avait été absolument fabuleuse dans les
années donc 68 69 vous tirer quand même
en 1969
donc si je perdais la liaison avec mon
chef je balançais 40 kilos tonnes sur le
terrain
ces textes et je suis pas le seul à
avoir d'autres officiers avaient été un
peu choqué d'ailleurs bon ça ça fait son
chemin puisque après ils avaient décidé
qu'effectivement il fallait un
hélicoptère sur le terrain je me suis
intéressé plus loin encore au nucléaire
parce que je me suis dit c'est pas clair
et j'ai je vous conseille une lecture
qui est celle de jean claude jean pierre
dupuy qui est un polytechnicien qui en
tiennent un stand for des cas étudiés
l'onu
r et il a il a recensé pendant la guerre
froide 17 alerte nucléaire est alors le
son souci c'était de dire qu'il faut que
j'aille voir les gens qui ont qui
étaient là aux commandes au moment de
ces alertes nucléaire entre l'est et
l'ouest et la réponse des militaires
qu'il a rencontré la plupart américains
quelques uns russe ça a été de dire
coup de bol 17 à l'air une alerte
nucléaire
le résultat coup de bol donc ça ça pose
vraiment des questions fondamentales par
rapport au problème nucléaire et ça
c'est une très très grande violence en
fait et qui va être suivi par la période
terroriste alors je ressens une certaine
époque dans les années mais 60 72 on
sent que la guerre froide va passer à
tomber donc on est quelques-uns se dire
on va poursuivre le commandement mais
dans d'autres dans d'autres
circonstances et je passe moi à l'époque
je fais l'entrée à l'école des officiers
la gendarmerie comme capitaine et là je
vais connaître une autre type de
violence dans la mesure où la
gendarmerie a été sûrement la première
institution qui a été vraiment
confrontés et qui a vécu avec le
terrorisme et qui continue à vivre avec
le terrorisme alors la première dates
importantes à retenir c'est 1000 1972
c'est à dire munich munich est un acte
fondateur au père actif du terrorisme
après plus rien ne va se passer comme
avant 1912 puis de 1973
c'est la création d'un par la
gendarmerie du gign c'est à dire le
groupe d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale qui est probablement un des
meilleurs groupes d'intervention au
monde et long cou vous voyez là les gens
en actions alors surgi gêne j'ai des
trois petites choses à vous dire qu'ils
sont très intéressants ils ont trois
grands principes fondateurs
le premier le premier principe fondateur
c'est
on protège on protège la vie c'est à
dire que la délégation de morts que vous
avez lorsque vous intervenez c'est
vraiment la dernière extrémité à preuve
la première chose à faire c'est de
protéger la vie deuxièmement ils ont
tous
ils ont des armes des révolvers c'est à
dire que le revolver a qu'une balle ou
premier tir
c'est à dire que tout à la la
psychologie la technique est fait pour
que cette première balle portent et pas
avoir un rattrapage avec une arme
automatique qui permet d'arroser voilà
et le troisième élément qui est
extrêmement important c'est de dire
lorsque vous êtes face à un adversaire
vous avez sept secondes avant cette
seconde au bout de sept secondes
vous êtes à égalité avec l'adversaire
voilà les trois grands principes qui ont
fait qu'ils ont fait le gign alors après
donc le gign malheureux en mille un
autre date importante c'est 1982 1982
c'est l'attentât de la rue des rosiers
on en reparle en ce moment et le
président mitterrand bon c'est un coup
politique énorme décide de faire venir
une cellule anti terroriste à l'elysée
qui est commandée par un jean da et donc
je fais partie de cette cellule alors là
on a eu des tas d'aventurés et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que on a été on a
été on a fait le joint entre les
mouvements terroristes révolutionnaire
issue un peu de la période de la guerre
froide
c'est à dire des mouvements vraiment
révolutionnaire action directe retard
mais même l'irlande la corse aussi toute
une série de mouvements qui qui se sont
éteints après et on a assisté à un beau
passage ce type de terroristes un autre
terroriste qui était le terroriste
moyenne orientale et en particulièrement
au liban notamment à partir du moment
1985 où on ouvre on nous enlève nos
otages
moi je vais être je vais me consacrer
surtout aux otages pendant toute cette
période
donc bon jeu j'ai retenu un certain
nombre de deux
deux choses 3 par exemple qui est
important de livrer la première c'est
qu'un jour j'ai fait un voyage à de
damas à beyrouth avec un authentique
preneur d'otages qui avait lui-même
participé à la prise d'otages dans
l'avion américain et il me devait me
conduire au liban et la seule chose
qu'il avait dans le voyage de comme
discours c'était de dire vivement que
j'arrive à beyrouth je vais pouvoir tuer
quelqu'un et je vais pouvoir m'exprimer
bon ça m'a pas fait peur parce que
j'avais des temps qui pense aux hommes
enfin c'est assez terrifiant ressasser
des choses à retenir quand on voit des
les yeux dans les yeux ce type de
terrorisme
deuxièmement ce que j'ai retenu ce qui
m'a impressionné aussi j'ai rencontré
rafik douce trafic d'oust était était le
patron des passe d'aaron des terribles
pentes de la rend qui avait fait cette
fameuse prise d'otage des américains
dans la voix salles américaines
je les ai rencontrés et quand je vais
rencontrer je peux vous dire que ce qui
était plus effrayé que moi à le
rencontrer ce délai syriens eux-mêmes
ça aussi c'est à garder en fait
troisième élément c'était que le
ministre syrien mustapha tlass avec
lequel j'avais une relation importante
et politiques m'amener lui même amalou
là pour me recueillir dans un centre
marial catholique ou qui étaient
vénérées aussi bien par les catholiques
de les sunnites
c'est bon c'est des choses qu'on le
regarde alors la vie à la vie a continué
moi j'ai repris mai 1989 je suis sorti
de cette cellule
mais la vie a continué avec les jeunes
que nous avions formé les outils que
nous avions formé et nous tombons sur
les deux les les deux actes forts de ces
dernières années qui sont marignane où
l'aja souvenez-vous à marignane c'est un
avion qui par kiki enfin mariane ses 24
25 20 et jusqu'au 25 et 26 décembre 1994
c'est un avion qui part qui est pris en
otage à alger et qui doit aller exploser
sur paris soit sur la tour eiffel soit
sur la tour montparnasse
la résolution de prise d'otage est faite
à marignane par le gign
et là je peux pas m'empêcher de vous
délivrer une explication un petit peu de
cette attaque qui qui veut qui veut dire
une chose c'est à dire que on peut pas
attaquer le terrorisme avec autre chose
que ses propres valeurs
hélas le gign il
il va riva réduire cette prise d'otage
en appliquant trois grands principes du
combat démocratique grecque le premier
le combat à coeur les grecs se
réunissaient l'été et tout le monde
les uns en face des autres combats à
coeur le gie jeune attaquante les les
quatre preneurs d'otages sont dans le
cockpit
deuxièmement place du chef place du chef
le chef était à droite du premier rang
là le chef qui est le commandant favier
à l'époque il est dans l'équipe d'assaut
troisième élément le jeune le jeune grec
pouvait être à côté de son grand père
dans le premier rang hélas le plus
ancien du gign côtoient dans l'équipe
d'assaut le plus jeune voilà trois ans
trois éléments du principe du les
principes du combat des mots tacaille
trick regrette qu'ils ont fait le pion
qui ont fait que ben ça a été une
résolution des plus belles résolutions
de prise d'otages le commandant favier
est aujourd'hui le directeur général de
la gendarmerie c'est à la mode assez
mythique je me permettre de le glisser
dans nos jeunes ce stade on l'a formé il
est il est depuis deux ans directeur de
la gendarmerie et un élément que je peux
pas m'empêcher de dire c'est que depuis
deux ans les la gendarmerie a deux fois
moins de suicides et donc c'est je
trouve que c'est très important par
rapport à un chef charismatique surtout
dans l'époque actuelle
alors bon on leur a ensuite nous avons
charlie charlie c'est bon c'est atroce
alors simplement je veux donner mon
opinion en analyse de charlie à savoir
qu'on n'est plus il faut abandonner
l'histoire de dire loup solitaire on
n'est plus dans le loup solitaire
on est là dans la théorie de l'ennemi
proche c'est-à-dire l'ennemi proches
lenny proches il est d'abord jouer de
l'autre côté à zawahiri al baghadi y tue
les modérés
musulman il tue les chrétiens et tue
tous ceux qui les gênent les
minoritaires et il purifie le camp et là
chez nous en fait les ennemis proches
fait que à un moment donné l'objectif
c'est de stigmatiser la population
musulmane entre parenthèses pour les
amener à rentrer dans le bon camp et
l'idée c'est tout simplement de faire
affronter voilà dans quelle logique
actuellement on se trouve à travers ces
attentats je à dammartin dammartin vous
savez que l'équipe akwasi sont fait
avoir demain je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de vous raconter quelque chose c'est à
dire que le premier qui a vu arriver les
les frères voiçi dans la prime riche son
c'est un gendarme de base il part il est
en patrouille le genre le type de
gendarmes de base que la vérité vous
arrêter sur la route vous demander vos
papiers enfin des bricoles locale ce
gendarme de base y
il a sa voiture qui est criblé de balles
et il approche il va vers les frères
coen
il approche d'un des frères klouchi il
lui tire dessus parce que l'autre était
armé et et lui met une balle dans le cou
un des frères y tombe par terre le coach
et le gendarme avait à cinq mètres le un
des frères kwasi par terre et le samedi
j'ai pas tiré parce que j'étais pas en
légitime défense
bon il y en a qui vont peut-être compter
ses mais c'est assez beau comme réflexe
est à dire que avec nos propres valeurs
ben parce que l'action de ce gendarme a
permis à fait que les faits recueillis
après se sont dit mais bon on est
coincés ils ont tenté une sortie qui a
effectivement ham n'a pas abouti et
puisqu'ils sont fait attraper par le gel
et la sortie des frères coen qui a fait
que les les policiers ont été obligés
d'intervenir dans le même temps et
souvenez vous ils ont été ils ont fait
un assaut à la légère
c'est à dire en rang serré et ça faut
saluer leur courage
et d'ailleurs ils l'ont payé assez cher
avec quatre blessés graves
me l'ont été parce qu'il n'avait pas le
choix de la manoeuvre ils sont obligés
par le temps de faire en même temps que
de l'autre côté au cas goût colis ben
ali aurait été capable de tuer
l'ensemble des preneurs d'otages
alors je ce je passe à autre chose et
mon discours en fait il est fait pour
les jeunes il est fait pour vous montrer
un peu mon expert de dire dans quelle
est ta en est surtout par rapport à
cette violence est la première
expérience que j'aime avec les jeunes ce
sont les miens j'ai deux garçons dont
deux qui ont 28 ans dont l'un est
officier qui a fait en trois ans
l'afghanistan le tchad et le
centrafrique
je vous dis moi quand je suis parti en
mission c'était pas un problème c'est
plutôt sympathique mais quand on est
papa ou quand on est maman
avoir un fils en afghanistan vous dormez
pas et puis le deuxième qui est qui et
c'est de ce soir tesson jumeaux et lui
il est ingénieur mais il dessine et pour
vous dire à quel point aussi il est
concerné par ce type de discours il m'a
fait de dessins pour pour le traité ou
des x mines
voilà donc le premier est évidemment
c'est le 11 septembre et le deuxième le
deuxième c'est charlie mais sachez que
charlie ce dessin a été sélectionné par
le huffington post
parmi les 40 meilleurs dessins du monde
c'est pas son travail mais voilà il a
fait ça lâche simplement ce pour rappel
que je vais dit au départ clausewitz et
rené girard est simplement vous donner
une idée forte avec un show crois
profondément c'est que à travers ces
théories du mimétisme de la violence je
crois que le terrorisme d'aujourd'hui
est le dernier vestige de la violence la
réponse au nucléaire
j'aborde pas la réponse qui pourrait
suivre mais je suis persuadé que le
terroriste globale est une réponse dans
le cadre du mimétisme de la violence
voilà mais on va je vais je vais achever
quand même ce cette présentation en vous
disant j'ai quand même des feux j'ai des
veuves des choses positives à vous dire
fait la première c'est que y at il une
solution comme
si les deux livres de ré d'éradication
la violence peut-on dépasser la violence
y at il un possible par rapport à
l'impossible et je pense que il ya un
conte le fameux concept de salomon vous
savez salomon qui qui va juger deux
femmes qui veulent se partager un bébé
il ya la maman qu'il ya une autre femme
qui veulent bébé et sur le monde ils
veulent couper en deux et la femme
la maman dit non moi je préfère le
donner à l'autre femme
et là vous avez une interprétation de
rené girard qui dit comme on l'a
toujours dit c'est pas salomon le dieu
c'est elle la femme qui va donner son
enfant donc moi j'y vois une possibilité
de voix humaine en fait de de briser ce
mimétisme de la violence en cas des
choses et je gémis notamment cette
phrase de pascal entre la vérité de la
violence ou sic est à méditer et enfin
deuxième élément est ce à ce dessin est
aussi un dessin d'un garçon qui l'a
envoyé hier tout simplement l'idée
l'idée est la suivante c'est que je
crois que on est au taquet l'occident
notre démocratie est un peu au taquet
pour régler un certain nombre de
problèmes
il faudra il faut les régler et
personnellement moi je crois je crois
beaucoup à l'afrique
il ya une génération d'africains que je
fais quand un peu surpris ou dans
l'institut que tu avais créé qui sont
absolument extraordinaires et ils ont en
plus s'ils peuvent ne renouveler notre
pensée et ont pu se croient ils
j'affirme ceci je dis que dans les 25
ans qui viennent c'est eux les africains
même si cet avis mesure du 25 ans je les
verrai part mais c'est pour les jeux
mais ces deux qui vont éradiquer le
fondamentalisme jeudi fondamentalisme
parce qu'il y aura pas que le vandalisme
contre qu'on connaît mais eux sont en
mesure d'éradiquer ils ont des moyens de
le faire et en fait je terminerai par
set
alors d'abord le dessin aussi c'est la
main dans la main et par la main tendue
et je terminerai pas cette magnifique
phrase de de léopold senghor qui disait
pour rester sur l'afrique l'afrique
c'est l'intuition et l'émotion l'europe
c'est la raison hellène merci de votre
torchon